if you're always losing Pokemon battles
to chumps with a level 17 Jigglypuff
it's time to step up your game I'm Lucy
and this is your legendary GameSpot news
update Nintendo and the Pokemon company
International have announced a new
promotion that allows players to pick up
some legendary Pokemon to use in Pokemon
X Y Omega Ruby and alpha sapphire
players you access that Pokemon bank
account will receive special versions of
Regirock regice and registeel each of
them will be level 50 and possess a
hidden ability to receive these three
legendary Pokemon players need to use
Pokemon link in their game after
accessing the Pokemon bank these
legendary Pokemon can only be received
once per account and are only available
until October 31st if that's not enough
the mythical Pokemon Calabi is also
available to players as a mystery gift
that can be downloaded online Calabi is
only available until March 24th so you
may want to get on that quickly Pokemon
Bank is a paid service available to
Pokemon X Y Omega Ruby and alpha
sapphire players with an annual
membership fee of $4.99 or and manage
their pokemon in private boxes online
for an annual subscription fee so have
you already got a Pokemon bank account
or have you already got the whole Reggie
family are you also confused by Pokemon
who aren't in the original
hundred-and-fifty let me know in the
comments or come by me on Twitter I'm at
Lisa James games thanks for watching and
for all your poker news and updates on
the upcoming Pokemon Sun and Moon keep a
GameSpot